loses last year understandably so his team
finished last in the NHL last year as the
golden kns and Ducks are underway from The
Fortress Nick to dump it in now Cam Fowler
said the Ducks the last team to play a game in
this new season Jamie Dale to track it down Puck
loose on the wall Stone in front his shot blocked
Away by C F despite not getting on the score sheet
the other night at San Jose Ben Hunton with
a shot save made by Gibson rebound and Maro
tried to bury it that got blocked by minling in
his first NHL game tonight good work in front of
the net keep that out of danger back the other way
lome he'll try to feed it in front up block second
chance and a save made by Aiden Hill now Hills
lost his stick did a good job getting right up
against that left post Jackson lome has a chance
in his third NHL game tonight out of University
of Minnesota lome out high with a wrist shot
blocked by Hunton he'll still without a stick
now has a chance to get it as Stone skates it out
up ahead of Conor down the wing being watched by
Mason McTavish in front Stevenson a chance they
have caught some of the pipe leushin will take
it back and settle things down for the Ducks
pressure little bit by amadio Carlson picks
it off Carlson walking in cuts down low he a
knock down Puck loose and swept away to the
circle loose Puck and patrono pushes it to the
boards held in by Theodor down low to Carlson shot
s Gibson Aro is open the puck never reached his
stick Michael in the dying seconds of the period
now trying to dance his way through and he scores
oh what a goal Jack eel with 1.3 to go in the
period a little bit of Juggle as he goes
across it's a loose Puck through two guys
and GTH tries to play stick on sck that's
not going to work it as eel takes it to
the net and it's a power move and then it's
just great hands in tight as he goes to the
forand as eel has his second of the season
and the first Power Play goal for the golden
knights golden knights scored a couple
of goals with a second left in the period
of their history Max Patch already had one
Jonathan Mar is so Jackel and Mark Stone now
Carlson [Music] dorv out top it's Hunton and
around the horn to Carlson Hunton again shot
and W and Carrick feeds it down the ice the
bgk now at a plus 33 in first period scoring
going back to last year that is the best Mark
in the NHL over the last season plus they have
scored first in all three games this year
now L off to Gori to again and Gibson able
to hold the four and lome F on the outlet pass
Stone took it away Stone right to the the save
gets and a rebound chance from Ron turned away
too the other end of the ice Mark stone with a
great opportunity to Mavish broken up by he and
the golden on the mar Andel they in hurry Mar
to and the shot blocked in front his breath
here's the two-on-one marot to eel the shot
he gets a glove on it just enough it's bouncing
around in the blue paint in the crease and Mar
still going for it it's a combination I believe
lome and Fowler get back Marshall can't get a
stick on that 20 to8 the shots for Vegas into
the Zone zigis looking shot and a glove save
hill their last win came on St Patrick's
Day against Columbus out High La throws
it towards it at tip sa made h he stop
the rebound on Terry Aiden Hill 12- one
in his last 13 games in this building
including the playoffs his only loss in
that stretch game five against Dallas
Conor to Stevenson and a backand TI
in beautiful feed by Paul conter to
Chandler Stevenson is second of the
season and made it two nothing here's the
play comes out watch the Ducks players are
going to go for a change right there and
McD does a good job quick transition to
Stevenson in the middle and him and
Conor play catch a quick little give
and go great sell by Conor on the shot and
a little pass over to Stevenson as he has to
tap barers and hunting out top Carlson looking
feeds it a broke right through Gibson and stay out
barely Jack eel leads everybody in this
game five shots so far for Jack at six
to lead everybody in San Jose Thursday
night Johnson tips it in not for long
Pall there now amadio to W breaking with
r w looking for a little bit of daylight
amadio has it trying to center it that hit a
leg and never made it throw to ronb Old nice
look to give themselves a little bit more of
a cushion Michael has it Stevenson in behind
the net gold Knight have eight shots on the
power play tonight theore rips it home Jay
Theodore with a blast his first of the Season
10 seconds into the power play and it's three
nothing power play they switch it up a bit
it's Stevenson's going to walk to that far
side that moves eel down lower which collapses
the Anaheim box that allows theor to come right
to the top of the circle look at this shot Jay
theor in his 400th game as a member of the vgk
it only took 10 seconds on that power play so
the golden knights have cashed in twice in the
man Advantage Toronto on the rush he was in
the Box not for long with Theodore scor on
the man Advantage Carlson looking a break he
got tangled up with McTavish back the other
way Str driv Drive turned away by Hill rebound
score Mason Mavish puts on the rebound and the
ducks have their first goal of the new season
as the Ducks there's the shot and the rebound
right to McTavish and said he'll was moving
to his right McTavish the trano missed on it
and it's a good Miss as Mavish right behind
him picks it up he has his first of the year
Carlson out top it's w he'll feed it
backside and dor denied by Gibson for
the vgk and a good chance for
Pavel Doria but Gibson shut it
down off this face he'll have the puck
in behind the there for Fowler Mahal
keeps it in barbashev beating it down to
Marc so in front to an and he missed the
net now he with a wrist shot tipped and
Gibson with a glove save a shot from he
at the point I think that just didn't get
tipped that actually skipped off the ice
extra skater for the Ducks haven't had a
shot in about five minutes he with an open
net Ron bu with an open net as follower went
down it'll be an easy one for Ron be to seal
it
great job on the face off scrum in and
he good patience here Outlet to Rond he
said yeah Bower just kind of caught an
edge the Ducks defenseman and allowed a
wide open Lane for rber as he just come
back home and beat Anaheim tonight the
golden kns off to a three and0 start all
three wins by identical scores of 4 to one